for more than seven years a battle raged
in Brooklyn over the government's right
to use eminent domain to seize private
property and sell it to a developer in
order to build a basketball arena that
nobody wanted for a team nobody roots
for this is the heart of the new
documentary film the battle for Brooklyn
which recently opened to sold-out crowds
in New York City following its multiple
wins for best documentary and best film
at the Brooklyn Film Festival the film's
story centers on graphic designer Daniel
Goldstein and his quixotic struggle to
keep his home out of the hands of New
Jersey Nets owner and real estate
developer Bruce Ratner when Ratner
decided to move the Nets to Brooklyn he
promised a new basketball arena
affordable housing Frank gehry-designed
architecture and jobs jobs jobs after
the financial collapse of 2008 the
project was scaled back to the point
that all that was left was the arena and
a parking lot reason TV sat down with
filmmakers Michael Galinski and Sookie
Holly to discuss how they came to the
project eminent domain abuse and
political perceptions of the film this
project of the Atlantic Yards project
was announced with this huge article in
the New York Times which we read and we
thought you know this doesn't this
doesn't sound like the area that we know
a couple days later we saw posters
saying stop the project I called the
number on the flyer it was Patti Hagan
and she was the person who started this
know this fight against this project
I've started shooting the next day with
her and I fought around for 10 solid
days as she led different reporters and
different people around the site trying
to explain what was really going on
we wouldn't we were not aware of him
domain abuse as an issue at all so we
didn't come to the saying like let's
find a project to highlight eminent
domain abuse as we got into it we we saw
how it was playing out in all these
different areas the film is filled with
colorful scenes of pure outraged
businesses being evicted after decades
in the neighborhood
elderly citizens being pushed from the
only homes they've ever known and
payoffs to union and community activists
Gratton Iran signed a community benefits
agreement with the city and with I think
eight community groups six of which
weren't even established groups before
the Atlantic Yards project was announced
and so they were supposedly negotiating
benefits for this community but
led to questions who did they represent
if they weren't an established group
already it came out later that they had
been paid and more being paid by Forest
City Ratner and even at this point there
aren't any jobs and guild as the you
know the group representing jobs but
they're funded by the developer so how
are they gonna how they're gonna fight
back if they say hey you know we need
jobs they their funding comes in the
developer so they can't some of the
writers have said it kind of paints the
government and the developer as you know
in bed together well they are the story
is so corrupt it's so corrupt it's
really hard to imagine how corrupt it is
when you know what's going on this kind
of process of top-down government is
endemic in New York it's epidemic the
whole Bloomberg model goes back to the
Moses model which we all know created
some benefits but incredible impacts as
well that neighborhoods are still have
not recovered from we do Q&A is at many
screenings we've been to festivals in
Canada and we showed a rough-cut
screening in Dallas and everywhere we
show it there is someone in the audience
who says that's just like what's
happening in Vancouver with the Olympics
well that's just like what happened with
Texas Stadium or you know someone will
also always relate it somehow to their
lives when they see the film you can't
build a community you can build a series
of buildings but it takes a long time
for community to form and community has
roots I mean you pull up a community by
its roots that community goes into root
shock the results of that are all kinds
of negative consequences for America I
mean the whole history of urban renewal
is is a nightmare
and yet liberal people still tend to
think that's a good idea because we're
building housing but you can't look at
benefits without looking at the
consequences since the project has kind
of pushed forward it has really not
created jobs and even the big supporters
of the project have come to us and said
you know the movie is very fair it had
seemed to you know divided on
ideological dividing lines when that
really made no sense at all because
people were conservative like the movie
people who are liberal like the movie
people who are in-between like the movie
because you know our tagline knows that
everybody hates kleptocracy everybody
hates it when the government is working
in junction with a favored partner to
enrich both of them
it's it's it's unamerican but what to
make of this is it's a movie
much like Erin Brockovich it follows a
character fighting in injustice
[Music]